it's been called a ticking time bomb the
aging sapphire oil tanker sits moored as
a floating oil storage vessel in the red
sea off the coast of yemen it holds more
than a million barrels of oil
a lot has changed in yemen since the
ship was constructed in 1976
thanks to civil war there it's had no
maintenance in seven years
environmentalists are very worried the
main concern is for a catastrophic level
leakage so either the the ship sinking
or a missile striking it either
intentionally or accidentally they point
to the long-term devastation caused by
the 1989 exxon valdez oil spill just off
the coast of alaska and the fact that
the staffer has four times as much oil
on board
but in a world full of emergencies
raising the 113 million dollars needed
to finally address the problem was no
easy feat for the united nations
we agreed on the first phase of the
contingency plan submitted by the united
nations
on wednesday yemen's foreign minister
announced they've raised enough money to
begin the operation an appeal to the
general public raised 200 thousand
dollars and enough international
attention to begin the work
we decided to help prevent the oil spill
because we wanted to save sea life from
the fishermen of yemen
for a country where more than 11 million
people rely on the u.n for food
assistance it's not just an
environmental disaster the u.n is trying
to avert
many people there rely on the ocean for
their livelihoods
it would create its own humanitarian
catastrophe along the coast communities
that were self-sufficient
from
fishing would no longer be
self-sufficient and they themselves
depended upon humanitarian assistance
for busy united nations yemen provides a
rare bit of good news first a truce to
slow the fighting and now finally enough
money to begin to replace the aging
tanker but they'll have to move quickly
and raise even more money to avert a
catastrophe
kristen salumi al-jazeera the united
nations